hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen zieht vorstellung und zwar
ist dieser zieht für die minecraft 1
punkt 6 punkt 1 und zwar habe ich
während meiner vorstellung für die
alstom 6.1 also wäre ich das gedreht
habe einzieht rausgefunden ich kann ja
nur ganz kurz zeigen wie der heißt der
heißt einfach desert ich wollte nämlich
eine wüste haben um die neuen wüsten bio
mit was da verändert wurde halt zu
zeigen
und wenn ich die welt jetzt einfach
generiere mit desert kommt keine wüste
sondern dass hier ethisch krass hohe
berge übelste extreme mountains biome
das ist einfach nur krass das ist
richtig hier sieht richtig geil aus wir
sind auch relativ viele schafe und
darfeld kies runter und wir können ja
echt zu durchfliegen erinnert mich
damals an die alten welt zieht sachen
die dann so mehr generiert wurden also
das sieht echt so unnormal krass geil
aus davon kann man nicht einfach nur ein
screenshot machen das sieht echt hammer
aus also das mal ganz kurz am rande neue
sieht vorstellung 1.6 punkt eins zieht
bedeutet also zieht es der hier
einerseits in kurzform oder einfach das
ist keine wüste ist einfach hier so übel
ist krass ihr seid einfach übels krasse
berge also das ist echt heftig und ich
habe den ich bin gerade dabei mein 1.6
neuerungen video aufzunehmen da habe ich
diesen zieht hier gerade entdeckt weil
ich eigentlich eine wüste haben wollte
aber das ist echt heftig also hier sind
sowas von viele krasse konstruktion
vielleicht gibt es noch viel mehr werden
wahrscheinlich unendlich viele mops
vorne drin sein
das ist eigentlich immer so bei solchen
sachen dass da die chance dass die mobs
bonner spawnen swaps pornos upon a
monster ein bisschen höher ist aber das
ist echt so krass und vor allem bestimmt
alles voll mit irgendwelchen hören ich
meine sieht man ja da geht den weg in
ihre höhle rein so was alles noch schon
wieder skelette am start
also das ist echt krass geil testet auf
jeden fall diesen zieht aus einfach
deshalb ein schreiben ist bond hier
unten
hab da ein relativ normales biom wenden
wenn man das so sieht denkt man so
normal und anderswo eine fette
gebirgskette also das echt krass krank
einfach nur das ist einfach nur übels
teil dieser sieht und probiert ihn
einfach aus kann eine sieht vorstellung
am rande schreibt meine kommentare
weniger mehr wollt und die können auch
neue reinschreiben also von mir aus auch
für 1.5 oder 1.6 ist mir egal aber vor
geil also wenn solche feiner daumen hoch
und dann simon
beim nächsten mal wieder